life is fundamentally different from
dead stuff or is it physicist Irvin
Schrodinger to find life this way living
things
avoid decay into disorder and
equilibrium what does this mean let's
pretend that your download folder is the
universe
it started orderly and got more and more
chaotic over time by investing energy
you can create order and clean it up
this is what living things do but what
is life every living thing on this
planet is made of cells basically a cell
is a protein-based robot too small to
feel or experience anything it has the
properties we just assigned to life it
has a wall that separates it from the
surroundings creating order it regulates
itself and maintains a constant state it
eats stuff to stay alive it grows and
develops it reacts to the environment
and it's subject to evolution and it
makes more of itself but of all the
stuff that makes up a cell no part is
alive stuff reacts chemically with other
stuff forming reactions that start other
reactions which start other reactions in
a single cell every second several
million chemical reactions take place
forming a complex Orchestra a cell can
build several thousand types of protein
some very simple some complex micro
machines imagine driving a car at 100
kilometres an hour while constantly
rebuilding every single part of it with
stuff you collect from the street that
is what cells do but no part of the cell
is alive everything is dead matter moved
by the laws of the universe so is life
the aggregate of all these reaction
processes that are taking place
eventually every living thing will die
the goal of the whole process is to
prevent this by producing new entities
and
this we mean DNA life is in a way just a
lot of stuff that carries genetic
information around every living thing is
subject to evolution and the DNA that
develops the best living thing around it
will stay in the game
so is DNA life then if you take DNA out
of its hull it certainly is a very
complex molecule but it can't do
anything by itself this is where viruses
make everything more complicated they
are basically strings of RNA or DNA in a
small hull and need cells to do
something we're not sure if they count
as living or dead and still there are
225 million cubic meters of viruses on
earth they don't seem to care what we
think of them
there are even viruses that invade dead
cells and reanimate them so they can be
a host for them which blurs the line
even more or mitochondria they are the
power plants of most complex cells and
were previously free living bacteria
that entered a partnership with bigger
cells they still have their own DNA and
can multiply on their own but they are
not alive anymore they are dead so they
traded their own life for the survival
of their DNA which means living things
can evolve into dead things as long as
it's beneficial to their genetic code so
maybe life is information that manages
to ensure its continued existence but
what about AI artificial intelligence by
our most common definitions we are very
close to creating artificial life in
computers it's just a question of time
before the technology we build gets them
and this is not science fiction either
there are a lot of smart people actively
working on this you could already argue
that computer viruses are alive hmm okay
so what is life then things processes
DNA information this got confusing very
fast one thing is for sure the idea that
knife is fundamentally different from
nonliving things because they contain
some non-physical element or are
governed by different principles than
inanimate objects turns out to be wrong
before Charles Darwin humans drew a line
between themselves and the rest of
living things there was something
magical about us that made us special
once we had to accept we are like every
living being a product of evolution we
drew a different line but the more we
learn about what computers can do and
how life works the closer we get to
creating the first machine that fits our
description of life the more an image of
ourselves is in danger again and this
will happen sooner or later
and here's another question for you if
everything in the universe is made of
the same stuff does this mean everything
in the universe is dead or that
everything in the universe is alive that
it's just a question of complexity does
this mean we can never die because we
were never alive in the first place is
life and death and a relevant question
and we haven't noticed it yet is it
possible we are much more part of the
universe around us than we thought don't
look at us we don't have any answers for
you just questions for you to think
about after all it's thinking about
questions like this that makes us feel
alive and gives us some comfort